el aspartamo el edulcorante artificial
puede causar cáncer pero es seguro de
consumir las dos evaluaciones parecen
contradecirse entre sí pero para los
científicos no es así aseguran que hay
información que demuestra que el
endulzante de origen químico podría
aumentar los riesgos de contraer cáncer
de hígado pero esos datos aún son
limitados
desde nuestro punto de vista de esta
clasificación del grupo 2b para el
aspartamo con evidencia limitada para el
carcinoma hepatocelular en humanos tiene
evidencia limitada para el cáncer en
animales de experimentación esto sugiere
fuertemente que necesitamos
investigación adicional para entender
mejor si el aspartamo plantea un riesgo
cancerígeno real el aspartamo es 200
veces más dulce que el azúcar y es casi
libre de calorías por eso ha sido tan
popular durante décadas y se utiliza
para hacer refrescos dietéticos goma de
mascar gelatina yogures y también
productos farmacéuticos como jarabes
un segundo estudio publicado el 13 de
julio dice que es poco probable que
genere cáncer si se ingieren menos de 40
miligramos por kilogramo de peso
corporal eso es el equivalente a una
docena de latas de refrescos sin azúcar
Entonces si los consumidores se
enfrentan a la decisión de tomar Cola
con edulcorantes o con azúcar creo que
debería considerarse una tercera opción
que es beber agua en su lugar
a los científicos les preocupa que los
niños se acostumbren a las gaseosas y al
aspartamo
con las posibles consecuencias de
consumirlos a lo largo de sus vidas